a good dream the dream of vaccinating
most americans against covet
is getting closer to reality with
president biden's announcement
that every adult in america should be
eligible by april 19th and that is less
than two weeks away not far
he also says we should have enough doses
for everyone by the end of may
which is really remarkable considering
where we were just a few months ago
weisha zhang is at the white house with
more on this weeja we all like good news
this is very exciting but
there's still a note of caution out
there too good morning what is it
good morning gail that's exactly right
because becoming eligible for the
vaccine does not guarantee you're going
to get one
right away it all depends on supply so
even as president biden expressed
optimism about all the progress the
country has made
he warned the pandemic remains dangerous
thanks what you're doing touring a
vaccination site in virginia
president biden stressed the importance
of getting more shots into arms
as infection rates soar in states that
have relaxed their coveted restrictions
we aren't at the finish line we still
have a lot of work to do
we're still in a life and death race
against this virus
while the new deadline to make all
adults eligible for the vaccine is april
19th
the administration has not changed when
it expects to have enough supply for
everyone the end of may just because
you're eligible doesn't mean you're
going to get it
ed brambaugh became eligible for the
vaccine in mid-january
along with everyone else who is 65 years
or older in san jose california where he
lives
but the 66 year old who looks for
appointments online
says he has not found one yet by the
time i get to that screen it says
we're not taking appointments we're sold
out too so it sounds like you've done
this
quite a bit every day for the last two
months
63 million adults in america are fully
vaccinated
and the u.s is currently administering
about 3 million doses a day on average
up from 1 million in january the white
house said it continues to ramp up
supply and expand vaccination sites
brumball said he's trying to remain
patient
while he waits it's frustrating that i
have to keep checking like this
but it's also understandable i mean you
know the entire nation is suddenly
trying to get a shot
the cdc announced that nearly 80 percent
of all
teachers school workers and other child
care workers have received at least
one dose of the vaccine which falls
short of the president's goal of
100 percent by the end of last month
however the administration
is on track to administer 200 million
shots within 100 days anthony
we just thank you